any La hip-hop you're listening to or
anybody who you [__] with out here uh
[__] Greedo just did his house arrest
time prison sentence out there and I
need to he did and I [__] agreed up and
I need to apologize to him right now on
your podcast because he sent me a song
that he wanted me to do I think he
wanted me to be on his next project and
I ended up getting my whole new phone so
I lost remember even though I still had
his Instagram but it was just like I
kind of had forgot that he even it
happens but when you just said it I was
like Credo damn you smile here damn we
were supposed to do a song together
so yeah I apologize to you my boy and if
you still want me to do that song matter
of fact on the DM when we leave here um